it's intoxicating like I said it's like  it's so arousing and it's fun and it's  to have somebody who responds to you on  that level like I said it's hard to find  we're not all meant to be matches sure  we can all have sex but we're not all  meant to be good matches and so when you  find that it's like you don't you I hold  on to it so tightly  like even men like there have been four  men in my life that I've responded to in  this way I'm only with one of them right  now they're all four in my life  I would entertain all four of them but  I'm only with one of them for various  reasons right  I don't they're all dominance and I  don't always get to choose when I have  time with them they choose and that's  that's challenging  it's a challenging space to be in